welcome back it is fry yay which means
we get to check on what's trending with
las vegas now host mercedes martinez she
is live this morning from the mix 941
studio mercedes good morning to you how
you doing this morning
good i am doing great it's so good to
see you guys and i've got a lot
happening this morning let's talk about
fireworking that is trending this
morning and no we're not talking about
pyrotechnics here apparently fireworking
is the new manipulative dating trend
that we all need to be aware of
fireworking is basically when someone
tries to make their ex jealous by
getting with you and then you can bet
they're gonna make a big show of it if
the person you're dating starts to
engage in lots of pda with you when
their ex is around that my friends is
fireworking some people who firework
will try to show off to their friends or
their family members and it's sad to say
they don't really like you next up
trending the hard seltzer trend this is
officially getting out of control you
guys bud light is selling an eggnog
flavored hard seltzer for the holidays
it's part of their new ugly sweater pack
now they did this last year but they
have three new flavors they have seltzer
nog sugar plum and cherry cordial now
the fir the fourth one is cranberry
which was also in last year's ugly
sweater pack you can start drinking them
november 1st john heather
seltzer nog i love eggnog but that is
just taking it to a gross level yeah
nothing makes
nothing makes eggnog better than bubbles
oh my gosh
let's switch gears and talk about
something else that i guess is a little
maybe gross adele you know she's been
trending she's not gross she's amazing
she released easy on me we had that last
week and of course she's done a ton of
press and she's been talking to
everybody but she has this really
interesting q a and mercedes this kind
of turns my stomach a little
yeah you guys she sat down with vogue
for their famous 73 questions interview
and we actually found out that one of
her most prized possessions
once belonged to a las vegas headliner
james corden who's a friend of mine but
also does carpool karaoke which i did
he did it with her and knew how much a
fan of of her i was and so he made her
spit her gum into piece of paper he
framed it for me
and it's my proudest possession
oh wow okay
um
she's got a framed piece of celine
dion's used gum you guys and it's her
most prized possession so you can chew
on that tidbit a quick reminder though
that her new album 30 it drops on
november 19th you know if if you too
john heather could leave me something
when i go in for las vegas now maybe
like a used coffee cup or
um a tissue that could soon become my
most present some hair
that's falling out
we have a mercedes we have a pile of
donuts here so what if we have a half
eaten donut how about how does that work
i mean i would eat actually i don't love
that
heather's like i mean
real quick getting mercedes you'll
remember when celine dion
they filmed the carpool karaoke they
were all here with james corden at
channel 8 for that so who that piece of
gum could have been here in our presence
as well oh wow
oh my gosh maybe it has like
john
somewhere embedded in it well we can
only hope dell doesn't even know how
lucky she is
mercedes thank you i'm not sure what
kind of rabbit hole we're going down
mercedes have yourself a good weekend
we'll catch up with you next week